[Music]
so at the capitol today as we told you
kamala harris will literally read
anything that arises on the teleprompter
in front of her
read a script that compared january 6th
to pearl harbor and 911 and we're
quoting dates that occupy not only a
place on our calendars but a place in
our collective memory december 7 1941
september 11 2001 and january 6 2020.
so you know it's easy to mock that it's
obviously ludicrous but it's also maybe
if you fought this country's wars
more than ludicrous maybe it's offensive
joe kent has fought this country's wars
for many years as a career soldier he's
now running for congress in washington
state we wish him well in that he joins
us now joe ken thanks so much for coming
on so what was your reaction when you
heard the vice president united states
say this
well obviously tucker i was deeply
offended because it's absolutely
appalling and just completely ridiculous
but what i want people to realize is
exactly what she's doing like you said i
fought these wars before and i've seen
this playbook ran before what kamala
harris is doing what joe biden is doing
is they're taking very powerful imagery
and they're saying that the attack on
pearl harbor the attack on 911 this is
the same thing that took place on
january 6 because that allows people to
compare trump supporters to nazis to
actual members of al-qaeda and with that
right imagery comes the justification to
turn the tools of the state against them
i can't believe you're running for
congress that is such a smart and
obvious analysis
and i wish i had said it before you said
it but i think that's exactly right
these words are not chosen by accident
correct
that's right now these are very
deliberate like i said we've we've seen
this playbook before there are echoes to
the lead up to the iraq war that they
have some intelligence there's something
they can't tell us but but we have to
trust them it's very very dangerous but
therefore we have to give them the
authorities to send us into a war a new
war but that war is here and that war is
against the deplorables trump supporters
whatever you want to call it and that
war has allowed them to deprive our
citizens of their constitutional rights
those that are still sitting in a gulag
in washington dc deprived of the rights
and then even other americans who
dissent from the current regime's
narrative just look no further than what
they did to the parents that had the
audacities to show up to school board
meetings they had the fbi
counterterrorism centers returned
against them
no wonder liz cheney is for this
so interesting dick cheney showed up
magically again today making a great
rear appearance so that's there's no no
coincidence there
it's also wrong joe ken thanks so much
for coming on tonight i appreciate it